بوتين يعطي الضوء الاخضر لصياد الليل
الروسي معلنا دخوله حلبه الحرب الاوكرانيه
والجيش الاوكراني يرفض اوامر الناتو واصفا
اياها بالانتحار امام روسيا
يكشف عن سلاح جديد في طريقه الى اوكرانيا
والاف الجنود الاوكراني يعودون من اسبانيا
فما الذي يجري وبوتين يفتح ذراعيه
لاردوغان معلنا لاستقباله على الاراضي
الروسيه وكلاب اخيرا تفصح عن السر الاسود
الذي اشعل الحرب وزيلنسكي يعلن عن قائمه
شروط جديده فهل يقبل الروس هذه المره
والولايات المتحده تجتمع بالصين وتمد يدها
لاصحاب العيون الضيقه من جهه وتتوعد من
جهه اخرى والجيش النيجيري يتحضر لطرد
الفرنسيين والتوترات تشتعل ليفرض الاتحاد
الاوروبي عقوبات لاغط الحلفاء في الحرب
الاوكرانيه تتغير المعطيات وتتبدل الاحداث
وتنعكس المواقف ولم نعد ندري عن اي
تحالفات نتحدث ففي كل يوم راي وموقف جديد
وها هو الضابط السابق في الاستخبارات
البريطانيه اليستر كراك يؤكد بان الجيش
الاوكراني غاضبا من مدربي وجنرالات حلف
الناتو الذين ينصحونهم بالذهاب لمواجهه
المواقع المحصنه للجيش الروسي والموت بشكل
جماعي واضاف ان الجنود قد شبعوا حتى
التخمه وطفح الكيل عندهم من عقائد حلف
شمال الاطلسي الامر الذي يضرهم الى
الاندفاع نحو مناطق التحصينات الروسيه
وخساره عشره الاف شخص شهريا برايكم هل
يقود النت الاوكران الى المحرقه حقا
الاجابه تاتي من صحيفه بيريوديكل
الاسبانيه مشيره الى ان اكثر من 30
اوكرانيا سينتهي تدريبهم في بلدان الاتحاد
الاوروبي في اكتوبر القادم ومؤكده لاجتياز
اكثر من 3000 عسكري اوكراني تدريباتهم في
اسبانيا ليعودوا الى اوكرانيا ضمن دعم
الناتو للقياف في الاثناء صرحت وزيره
الدفاع التشيكيه يانا تشيرنو خوفا بان
بلادها تخطط لتزويد بدفعه جديده من
المروحيه الحربيه واعلنت تشيرنو
ان المروحيه الروسيه من طراز 124 بي و 35
التي يستخدمها الجيش التشيكي تعمل بشكل
ممتاز بالرغم من ان استخدامها استمر لفتره
اطول مما كان متوقعا
يا لك رميكم الحاتمي يا هؤلاء اتدعمون
ثياب باسلحه قد انتهى وقتها الافتراضي
مهلا مهلا فها هي صح
يفه في البينتاغون تكشف ان كيا ستتسلم اول
عشر دبابات امريكيه ابرامز في منتصف
سبتمبر لتعزيز القوات الاوكرانيه في
هجومها المضاد هذا وتعتزم الولايات
المتحده الاسراع في تسليم 31 دبابه الى
اوكرانيا بحلول الخريف فهل تشهد هذه
الدبابات مجزره
كسابقاتها من دبابه ليوبارد الالمانيه لكن
الغرب لا يكل ولا يمل عن دعم اوكرانيا حيث
قال عضو البرلمان الاوكراني
ان اوكرانيا تسلمت خلال اغسطس الماضي
مساعدات ماليه من حلفائها بقيمه السته
مليارات دولار لرفض ميزانيتها الخاويه عن
اي ارقام نتحدث دعونا ننتقل الى ميدان
المعارك فقد اسقطت مروحيه 28 الهجوميه
الروسيه الملقبه بصياد الليل مسيره
الاوكرانيه لاول مره في تاريخ المعارك
الجويه حيث يستحيل على الطائره والمروحيات
تدمير المسيرات الجويه لصغر حجمها وكان
الروس يقولون لقد وجدنا العلاج لداء
المسيرات وها نحن نتصفح المصدر امامكم كما
تشاهدون في الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه
في المقابل اعلن عمده موسكو ان الدفاعات
الجويه دمرت مسيره اوكرانيه فوق ضاحيه
ليوبيرتسي استهدفت العاصمه فيما اعلن حاكم
مقاطعه كارسيك اسقاط مسيرته استهدفت محطه
نوويه في المقاطعه ولضمان سلامه الملاحه
الجويه تمنع تاجيل 32 رحله والغاء 20 في
مطاري فونو كوفو ودومو ديدوفو المعارك
تزداد حده يا ساده لترد القوات الجويه
الفضائيه الروسيه بانها وجهت ضربه دقيقه
بصاروخي اسكندر لمبنى بمنطقه كراسنو
ارميسك في جمهوريه دوناس اثناء اجتماع
لقاده عسكريين اوكرانيين كبارا في المبنى
واما المصدر هذه المره فهي القناه الرسميه
للحكومه الروسيه على ذات السياق دعا عمده
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو
الى توسيع الدفاعات الجويه في المدينه
لمواجهه الارتفاع الملحوظ فيها هجمات
الطائره المسيره الاوكرانيه وافاد
السوفياني بنصب منظومه دفاع جوي جديده في
الاسابيع الاخيره في مناطق مختلفه من اجل
حمايه المدينه فيما اعترف امين مجلس الامن
القومي الاوكراني اليكسي دانيلاف بان كييف
بدات تطوير صواريخ ماداها 700 كلم في شتاء
2020 وهذا ما يؤكد اهميه العمليه الروسيه
لنزع سلاح اوكرانيا ومنع انضمامها للناتو
وفق ما يقوله لكرملين لكن مع اخبار هذه
المعارك عادت اخبار الوساطه للظهور من
جديد وبايدي تركيا وان لم ينتج شيء عن
تهدئه الحرب فيكفي ان يعاد اتفاق الحبوب
اليس كذلك نعم وقد اكد المتحدث باسم
ان الرئيسين الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
سيجريان محادثات في مدينه
في الرابع من سبتمبر الجاري بينما قال
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه بعد اجتماع عقده مع
نظيره التركي هاكان فيدان في موسكو ان
روسيا اوضحت ما يجب على الغرب فعله
لاستعاده العمل باتفاق الحبوب لافتا الى
ان روسيا ستعود الى الاتفاق لافتا ان
روسيا ستعود الى الاتفاق حال اختفاء
شروطها بدوره اكد وزير الخارجيه التركيه
اعداد انقره مبادره شديده لاحياء الاتفاق
نحن بالانتظار يا هذا لياتي الدور على
الرئيس الاوكراني فلا ديلنسكي والذي اكد
انه بدون استعاده القرمودومباس وباقي
الاراضي المحتله فانه لن يكون هناك سلام
دائم مع روسيا الجهه المقابله رد الكرملا
بان شروط هذه سخيفه ولن تقبل بها موسكو
اطلاقا ليعود زيلينسكي ويقول ان تركيزه
والمسؤولين الحكوميين والعسكريين ينصب على
الخطوط الاماميه والعمليه الهجوميه ومن
اوكرانيا نتوسع قليلا نحو الحدود حيث اعلن
قائد القوات المشتركه الاوكرانيه رفع
جاهزيه الوحدات المنتشره عند الحدود
نعبلاروسيا وفي جميع المواقع القتاليه من
جهته هدد وزير الداخليه البولندي باغلاق
كل المعابر والطرق وعزل بيلاروسيا عن
اوروبا في حال حدوث اي استفزازات على
الحدود حسب تعبيره جاء ذلك بالتزامن مع
بدء بيلاروسيا مناورات عند حدودها الغربيه
مع اوكرانيا وفولندا بمشاركه دول منظمه
معاهده الامن الجماعي هل هناك خ
الاحتلال بولندا دعونا نراه الاحداث
والتطورات اعلن متحدث البنتاغون باترك
رايدر ان قائد القوات الامريكيه بمنطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهذا
الادميرالو عقد مؤخرا اجتماع نادرا مع
مسؤولنا الصينيين مشيرا الى ان الجانب
الامريكي يعلن على الدوام رغبته في فتح
قنوات للاتصال وذلك لتفادي حدوث اخطاء بين
القوتين النوويتين وفي تايوان رئيس اللجنه
القوات المسلحه الامريكيه في الكونجرس روب
ويتمان برد حازم اذا تعرض التايوان الى
الهجوم واضاف رئيس
ان مجلس النواب الامريكي يعمل على حل
مشكله تاخير مشتريات دفاعيه من الولايات
المتحده الى تايوان بقيمه 19 مليار دولار
لم يتم تسليمها بعد والى احداث النيجر حيث
قالت هيئه الاركان الفرنسيه ان الجيش مست
للرد على اي توترات جديده تستهدف المنشات
العسكريه والدبلوماسيه في النيجر في مكان
المجلس العسكري في النيجر قد قرر سحب
الحصانه الدبلوماسيه الممنوحه للسفير
الفرنسي وامر الشرطه بترحيله وعائلته الى
خارج البلاد من جهه اخرى اعلن المجلس ايضا
تعليق كافه انشطه المنظمات الدوليه في
مناطق العمليات العسكريه هذا وقال مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يتجه لفرض عقوبات على
قاده الانقلاب في النيجر واكد عدم تلقي
طلب من المجموعه الافريقيه لتمويل اي عمل
عسكري محتمل وقال ان الدعم الاوروبي مستمر
لمجموعه ايكوست وما تقرره لتسويه الازمه
في النيجر
[موسيقى]